Okay, let's get back to the phones at (617)
830-4750 a lot of very high quality calls
today.
Let's see if we can keep it going with our
caller from the seven six zero area code.
Who's calling today from seven six zero.
Hi David.
This is Amy from San Diego.
Hey Amy, what's going on?
So kind of piggy backing off the last caller,
he started making me think about, um, Edward
Snowden and, uh, I'm Aka a Bernie supporter
and I'm wondering if you think Bernie would
do anything that would allow Edward to come
home?
I actually don't know how you feel about him,
but, uh, about Edward in particular, but yeah.
Um, I, you know, I don't, it's very hard to
know.
W would anyone have predicted when Donald
Trump was running for president that uh, he
was going to get involved in whatever the
person's name was that Kim Kardashian mentioned
to him or whatever?
Like, no, I mean, there was that, that was
pretty unpredictable.
So it's unpredictable.
It's hard to say what it is that Bernie would
or wouldn't get involved in, but I've not
seen, and correct me if I'm wrong, if you
know, otherwise, I've not seen any evidence
that Edward Snowden is high on Bernie's list
of priorities.
Yeah, I don't, I don't think so either.
I don't know.
I guess for me personally, I'd just gotten
into like the master valence in and realizing
how big it is in the country and all of that.
And um, but yeah, you're right.
I don't think that's necessarily number one
on Bernie.
What, what, what would you like to see happen
with Edward Snowden?
Well, mainly I just for one note has said
like, he would come home if he had gotten
a fair trial and so the reason he's not getting
a fair trial is we can be tried with the espionage
act.
So, I mean, I don't want him to get charged
with anything, but I mean, I guess Bernie
could lower or change whatever.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I don't think there is any
path to Edward Snowden not being charged if
he comes to the United States.
I think that I've read some opinions that
say espionage act is really, you're, you're
interpreting it pretty loosely if you apply
it to Edward Snowden and maybe it should not
apply.
I think that's a conversation to have, but
I don't see any way that he comes back and
just has no charges.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Yeah, no, you're right.
But I think that's reasonable.
I think that that makes sense.
All right, Amy, thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you.
Yeah.
Thank you, David.
All right, take care.